i was surprised by this one of all the
options out there eight million is a lot
of money for a guy who frankly hasn't
done much miles uh in recent years and
maybe he's been holding something back
we don't know about but but it just
seems like a a risk calculated risk but
a risk for the cardinals well again it's
it's the cardinals becoming this
destination spot and it seems like
they're trying to take advantage of the
fact that kyler murray is in his rookie
contract and now that you basically have
this window right be when teams can go
for it when they've got the qb on the
rookie contract it just seems like
they're trying to push all their chips
into the middle and they try to get a
veteran wide receiver in aj agree look i
think
it's weird what his stats were in 2020
if you look at i mean he got 104 targets
he only had 47 receptions 523 yards a
couple of touchdowns a 45 catch rate
that's just strange i mean it's it's way
down from what it was for most of his
career which was at 60 from 2011 to 2018
obviously he didn't play in 2019 with
the injuries so he's going to be 33 in
july and i think he does still have all
his extremities left mike but i don't
know how much he has left in the tank
and what exactly he can provide for that
cardinals offense
five yards per target this year the
lowest in his career by far the prior
low was 7.5 yards per target and that
was a year that he had a thousand
receptions because he or a thousand
yards a thousand receptions would be a
record a thousand yards not a record he
had 143 targets that year but i mean
franchise tagged last year another guy
like a hunter henry franchise tagged and
then just gone the next year and the
bengals never really seriously exploring
the possibility of keeping him 2019 he
didn't play at all remember they had a
practice in dayton
as part of the nfl's 100th season
celebration and he messed up his ankle
and never played that year
i i just hey i'll believe it when i see
it now he's got deandre hopkins and
christian kirk
so
he'll he'll enjoy single coverage
something that he didn't enjoy for most
of the early years of his career but
we'll see what he can do with it my
first thought when i saw it miles is
even though larry fitzgerald has yet to
announce his intentions and technically
he's a free agent for the first time in
his career as of right now and can sign
with any team
signing aj green means that larry
fitzgerald isn't coming back because
you're not going to pay fitzgerald to be
the fourth receiver and you're not going
to have
hopkins kirk green fitzgerald four guys
active on game day none of them playing
special teams then you get andy isabella
who's going to be fifth on the depth
chart at best he does some special teams
but i i you there's no spot the the
larry fitzgerald spot has gone to aj
green and if fitzgerald plays in 2021
he's going to be playing for somebody
else
yeah maybe he goes to tampa and he says
hey brady you want to help me win a ring
and like that's just
you know the real destination spot
becomes tampa bay but it's interesting
because larry fitzgerald you know i
still think he has some ability i almost
feel like they didn't quite use larry
fitzgerald in the way that they could
have last year down there in arizona you
know he had 54 catches 409 yards a
touchdown it's not it's not to me like
he can't do anything and i think he does
provide value i believe we all saw that
clip of uh the the cardinals at the
49ers game where he's running the ball
into the official so they make sure that
they can spike it and they make sure
that they have enough time there in a
two-minute drill to to go on the field
win so it i think larry fitzgerald does
still have value even though he's going
to be playing for his 127th season in
2021 if he decides to play but it is a
little interesting that he has not yet
decided or at least publicly announced
whether or not he's going to play
because last year that happened in
mid-january we're already in mid-march
right now so i think from the cardinals
standpoint they had to say all right we
need to make sure that we have all of
our bases covered and that's why it
makes sense to go after aj green because
he's a little bit younger and he
ostensibly maybe does have a little bit
more ability that works out in that
offense
i never thought he was a guy who would
play for another team and i still don't
believe he'll play for another team he
was a ball boy for the vikings in 1998
when they had chris carter jake read
randy moss and his father who still is a
sports writer in minnesota said it's
been about 10 years ago that he believes
eventually larry fitzgerald will play
for the vikings but they're not a super
bowl contender so why would that be your
last stop i think when he said last year
and i think it was november-ish
that
um
if the cardinals win the super bowl
he'll retire well nobody looked at the
cardinals as a super bowl contender i
just wonder whether that was his clue
then that's his first sprinkling i got
one more year after this one and i'll
consider playing for a super bowl
contender to try to cap my career with a
ring and the bucks would make sense the
chiefs would make sense he's a guy who
brings leadership he brings cashe not
the cache is going to win football games
but he brings something to your team
that that
that smart
heady stuff that we saw when he runs the
ball in to to get the the clock killed
so i i think that
i think there's still gas in the tank
the question is whether he wants to
leave arizona and cap his career
somewhere else it's not like anybody in
arizona would be upset with him you know
i've always had this weird sense that
not always but just over the past few
years that maybe you'd like to get into
politics and uh you know you don't want
to lose votes in arizona by leaving the
cardinals i just think at this point in
his career nobody would care if he did
yeah i mean it feels like i mean when i
was covering the rams and the rams would
often go down to arizona toward the end
of the season it felt like every year
they were saying goodbye to larry
fitzgerald i feel like there was one
year it might have been even 2018 where
they were like had the 12 days of larry
fitzgerald larry fitzgerald's 12 best
plays and then larry fitzgerald threw a
touchdown pass and it was like wow
that's kind of the only thing larry
fitzgerald hasn't done and now he's
played for two more seasons so
i feel like they've been saying goodbye
to larry fitzgerald just in case for the
last few years and if there's one place
that larry fitzgerald wants to go to
finish his career and have a good chance
of getting a ring i agree with you mike
there probably would not be much
animosity from arizona
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports